j'accuse jamiroquai
jay kay
bonsoir jay kay le leader du groupe
jamiroquai 20 millions d'albums vendus
et quand on écoute on comprend pourquoi
jamiroquai you you know jean michel
jarre yonne jean michel jarre et absolu
lui évidemment je le connais je lui je
suis un grand fan de jean michel jarre
est ce que jean-michel pour venir pour
serrer la main de jamiroquai
jean-michel jamais recoins il vient de
dire qu'il était un grand fan de un
grand fan de vous est ce que vous êtes
un grand fan de lui
oui absolument c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui est qu'il ya un style totalement
particulier qui je pense qu'on se
retrouve c'est qu'il a une manière de
traiter le son qui est totalement unique
dans dans un taudis catégorie de musique
totalement différente mais mais c'est
avant tout dû songer meira quoi et c'est
pour ça que depuis le départ moi c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a branché mais
immédiatement indépendamment de son
talent de performeurs et de haut niveau
du son c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
immédiatement cesser décalé par rapport
à tout un genre de musique qui
existaient et qui en a fait une pâte qui
viennent une patte unique particulier il
te connais d'accord mais do you know
jean pierre raffarin
merci jean michel merci d'être venu
saluer
salut journée
jamiroquai sera une grande tournée
européenne cet été il sera le 21 juillet
à golfe juan et le 22 juillet à nîmes
voilà donc si vous l'aimez
allez le voir voilà alors jamiroquai
quand on s'interroge sur cette grâce ce
que vous avez dans la la composition
musicale et dans l'interprétation vocale
en fait on trouve la réponse dans votre
biographie votre mère karine qu'elle
s'est lancée à 14 ans dans une carrière
de chanteuse de jazz
à 17 ans elle était sur la même scène
que les beatles que ronnie scott ou
dizzy gillespie
est-ce que c'est finalement sac c'est
cette jeunesse se baigner dans la
musique qui vous a donné cette grâce oui
absolument
effectivement ma mère une influence très
importante sur moi depuis que j'étais
tout gamin
moi j'étais dans le coup lisse et
j'étais souvent avec les musiciens là et
elle s'occupait des musiciens et les
enfants d'un musicien ou mais en fait
bien sûr ça quand elle était sûre celle
là il avait plutôt été vraiment des
grands comment dès lors qu'ils jouent à
19 h 30
c'était vraiment tous le sont tous à la
musique que j'ai entendu qu'il a bercé
mon enfance et donc c était vraiment
l'influencent numéro un pour moi s'il
très bonne école pour vous effectivement
et à l'âge de 4 ans pendant un show de
votre mère vous entrez sur scène en
criant maman maman maman vous en
souvenez de ça adieu même appel parce
que c'est très bien traversé j danseuse
est bon c'est pour ça que j'aime autant
les choux et les chaussures à l'heure
actuelle parce que j'étais toujours
encadré 2
qui était grande avec des grandes jambes
des grandes chaussures que les grands
chemins c'est un peu chiche question
chaussures m'enfin bon alors à la même
époque
votre premier grand témoin musical c'est
shaft par isaac hayes ça a été vraiment
pour vous une révélation
j'ai tellement sur moi c'est incroyable
est ce que toutes ces infos non mais
c'est vrai c'est super mais vous avez
raison
effectivement mon père avait une table
et puis il y avait un petit tracteur
rouge mais moi je pédalais là autour de
7 analystes ont changé c'était vraiment
la première chose voir aussi que faisait
partie ma mère faisait sortir 264 jouer
en club avant qu'il soit vraiment très
connu donc effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui s'inscrit dans la durée toutes
cette histoire avec la musique
maintenant il faut que vous me demandiez
ce que vous me disiez ce que j'ai pris
tous les jeux
donc voilà comment s'explique le bout
musicale de jamiroquai et son
instabilité aussi et puis alors on
découvre quand on étudie un petit peu
votre biographie
pourquoi vous aimez tellement les
voitures c'est parce que votre mère
n'avait pas de véritable pied-à-terre et
vous avez passé une bonne partie de
votre enfance à l'arrière des voitures
ce qui explique votre passion pour les
bolides sans doute vous demandiez à
votre mère d'accélérer quand vous étiez
sur la route avec elle voilà acheteurs
et va pas me font c'est vrai que j'adore
toujours les sièges arrière des
blessures des yeux mais vous voyez en
fait effectivement c'est vrai que j'ai
grandi sur les autoroutes
c'est là que c'est de là que me vient
cet amour qu'on les vôtres parce que
quand vous été placées aux quatre coins
du pays à longueur de temps et bien tout
ce qu'il vous reste à faire passer
regarder les bagnoles et donc itanium
années 70 c'était très différent que
vous intéressantes qu'elles ne sont à
l'heure actuelle elle avait une triumph
votre mère j'avais une ce triomphe 13 60
alors voilà c'est pas facile quand on
est enfant de de bouger et de faire des
études jamiroquai jay kay a eu une
enfance un peu compliqué il n'en pense
pas facile à l'époque votre mère
travaille beaucoup parfois vous rentrez
chez vous il ya personne qu'on vous
rentrez et vous n'êtes pas assez grand
pour mettre la clé dans la serrure et
vous êtes obligés d'aller voir les
voisins en pleurant pour qui vous ouvre
la porte de chez vous ce n'était pas
drôle tous les jours j'ai pu être en
internat
dès l'âge de 4 ans j'étais innocent
jeunes gamins de l'école j'ai été dans
cet internat différents tout simplement
parce que ma mère devait travailler et
donc les gens ont frappé des premiers
jours tout simplement parce que j'avais
parlé à nos camarades pendant le repas
de foire en fait j'avais pas les aviez
droit de parler à certaines personnes
mais bon papa lui en l'occurrence et
donc c'était très strictes et donc ils
m'ont ils m'ont battu et je pense que ça
m'a donné l'indépendance dont je jouais
à l'heure actuelle et il faut bien voit
ainsi que ça a développé en moi cette
indépendance vous savez qu'il faut
grandir rapidement qu'il faut faire ses
preuves
voilà alors en parlant d'indépendance à
l'âge de 16 ans vous discutez avec votre
mère vous devenez tagueurs vous allez
vivre dans un squat vous fait des petits
boulots et vous avez même vendu du shit
c'est vrai vous avez vendu du haschich
jay kay amg vendus du chiffre mais vous
pourrez d'ailleurs bien fut même
toujours ce serait sympa
il ya des fois où du moment où si vous
voulez faire de la musique et bien à ce
moment là vous allez faire tous les
effraie il faut pour y arriver est
effectivement là je me suis rendu compte
qu'il fallait que je fasse un certain
nombre d'efforts et que je fasse un
certain nombre de choses que je récupère
l'argent nécessaire pour cause pour
m'acheter matériel dont j'ai besoin pour
me lancer
et puis ensuite j'ai pu sortir de tout
ça et vite moi je savais ce que je
voulais faire ça c'était j'avais quelque
chose de fixe être là dessus sur la
musique c'était ce que je voulais c'est
vrai c'était vraiment fait du lâche
libanais de stups nous fait plein de
petits boulots pour essayer d'accumuler
de l'argent vous n'êtes pas très heureux
à cette époque là et un jour vous vous
dites si tu veux faire de la musique
fait de la musique ne fait plus que de
la musique
même si tu dois mourir de faim à ce
moment là vous retournez chez votre mère
vous enfermer pendant six semaines dans
la salle de bains transformé en studio
et là vous créez en très peu de temps en
fait le concept jamiroquai et le logo le
logo avec les buffalos manière que vous
inventez ça très rapidement finalement
j'ai voulu sortir de tous les problèmes
que je traversais je suis rentré chez
moi j'étais dans ma chambre je me suis
assis là et je me suis dit qu'on alors
qu'est ce que je vais faire maintenant
il faut que je fasse quelque chose que
je présente quelque chose à l'entreprise
j'ai dit ce que l'on produit fini donc
pas ce que je vais trouver pas de nom
pour le groupe donc la première chose
que j'ai faite c'est que j'ai essayé de
dessiner ce type là bon c'est décidé
parce que je me suis dit que c'est qu'un
symbole que les gens les reconnaît
facilement et je me suis dit bercy le
voit régulièrement ils vont le
reconnaître même s'il ya pas de nom et
c'est le cas voilà alors le premier
producteur qui a reçu votre cassette au
départ il a cru que c'était une diva
noir en écoutant votre voix il pouvait
pas imaginer une seconde que c'était un
jeune anglais c'est une voie que vous
avez hérité de votre mère
oui absolument c'est une bonne charité
en fait j'ai fait une interview radio
est longue et le type m'a dit c'est qui
cette femme noire qu'on entend la jib
annoncé voilà
et là c'est le succès un succès
considérable et rapide vous donnez une
star mondiale vous donnez milliardaire
et vous devenez aussi cocaïnomane et le
groupe a fortement grandi à l'époque
c'était les années rock'n'roll et les
filles avec canal de la vodka
il ya eu des enchaînements donc l'idée
c'était pas trop d'aller plus loin
c'était cette époque pour arriver à
monter sur scène c'était simplement
autour de la scène et on atterrit c'est
parce qu'une fois que vous avez fait
votre spectacle il fallait atterrir et
l'atterrissage parfois été un peu
difficile donc on tomber là dedans ça
c'est bon c'est fini maintenant je suis
toujours là je suis content j'ai été je
suis propre depuis cinq mois
oui c'est terminé s'est terminée
aujourd'hui grâce à un ami à vous qui
s'appelle olic est un ami de longue date
et un jour vous rencontrez ce au lit
vous dit qu'il a des problèmes d'argent
vous lui dites que vous avez des
problèmes de drogue et vous lui dit je
vais te payer pour tu me surveille et
effectivement depuis le 1er janvier 2004
vous n'avez pas pris de drogue vous avez
retrait bien là quelqu'un qui a essayé
de me vendre je lui dis non à jeudi à
orly à l'époque c'était le manager sur
place et je l'avais beaucoup fait des
voyages et pendant sa vie dans les tours
en amérique en amérique du sud un peu
partout et donc il était dans le creux
de la vague et donc je dis jeudi à liège
l'aider à redevenir heureux donc je dis
allez on est potes
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides à tonton
asept donc combien tu as les jeux x de
ton salaire tu vas bosser pendant 24
heures sur 24 on va se lever le matin
le courir on va faire ceci au travers on
va arracher toutes les pages des
endroits où on peut sortir et c'est donc
et si j'avais pas arrêté de faire ça je
n'aurais pas pu faire dynamite et voilà
giresse
extrait du nouvel album de johnny
m
alors thierry key de depuis que vous
avez arrêté la cocaïne vous êtes
beaucoup plus agréable avec les
journalistes
il faut bien voir avec les paparazzi
anglais c'est qu'ils sont vraiment hyper
vorace et c'est vraiment une mue qui
veulent me voir sortir des clubs un peu
comme ça c'est ça qu'ils veulent voir
site la photo qu'ils veulent faire et
donc de temps en temps dans fou un petit
pain d'antan celle pour des coûtants
devenu un good guys un bon garçon et on
va faire une interview good guys
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que vous buvez encore
un peu quand même
oui combien son problème ouais votre
canne tonique pas couler est-ce que vous
fumez des pétards de temps en temps
autant qu'avant mais ça m'arrive
le reste de ton les banel j'en ai besoin
après cette émission est ce que vous
êtes passés devant un juge depuis moins
d'un an
oui j'ai passé devant un juge
j'ai perdu mon permis de conduire dont
j'ai récupéré entre temps mais j'ai
permis donc permis de permis conduite
parce que je vous disais trop vite non
beaucoup trop vite vous mettez des pots
catalytiques à vos ferrari en fait
toutes les ferrari sont équipées de pots
catalytiques
absolument et si vous partiez des
chapeaux il sera en fourrure synthétique
oui complètement non en fourrure
naturelle jamais jamais est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un good guys
est-ce que vous pensez que rien n'est
plus beau que le sourire d'un enfant jay
il faut que je raconte quelque chose je
suis bon mais faut pas exagérer non
sécuritaire
a sion la gare est toujours bien les
minettes qui pour des mini jupes et des
j'ai eu des bottes ajustements justement
est ce que vous demandez toujours la
carte d'identité d'une fan avant de
coucher avec elle pour être sûr qu'elle
n'est pas mineure mon dieu non non non
est ce que maintenant vous êtes un good
guys vous rêvez d'un duo avec mariah
carey non la dernière fois que j'ai vu
d'ailleurs elle s'est pointée comme ça
il n'y avait que les gens qui
l'entourent et gta dans le couloir et
les venues elle est passée comme ça
parce que je te fasse du baisemain
[Applaudissements]
penser que l'amour pourrait sauver le
monde
si vous vous débarrassez ce jour je
bouge to speech unit deux semaines
peut-être que l'on pourrait sauver le
monde
[Applaudissements]
tiens
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus